you know optimus prime but do you know
optimus primal when it comes to the
transformers universe there's more than
meets the eye
before the beginning
there was primus and there was unicron
now finding one definitive transformer's
timeline is impossible as hasbro the
company that owns transformers has never
declared a prime reality but if you
weave in and out of the different
universes that make up the transformers
incredibly complex multiversal tapestry
you'll soon realize that most sagas are
variations of the generation 1
narratives the original story is first
told in the transformers original 1984
cartoon and marvel comic book series
patterns emerge commonalities appear and
from the many we can pull one covering
it all would take a book or three but we
put together a unified timeline with a
few deviations to explore the really
unique diverging realities to help you
navigate the increasingly complex
transformers multiverse so if you're
ready
let's roll
light and dark ordering chaos good and
evil primus and unicron first introduced
with zero background in 1986's
transformers the movie the cartoon
eventually elaborated that unicron was
built by a mad genius that explanation
was somewhat underwhelming for such a
momentous character so the comic books
later assigned unicron a more fitting
origin for simon furman's comics unicron
is a dark god locked in an eternal
battle with the light god primus
the idea soon solidified into an
integral part of transformer lore though
like any myth the details constantly
shift
first primus and unicron are from a lost
pantheon of gods and by issue number 74
unicron is the destroyer of the previous
universe while primus had been born to
protect the current universe the
sentient core of the universe known as
the one created unicron then split
primus off of him by the 2013 hardcover
history the covenant of primus the two
gods become a singular being that
develop opposing personalities and split
into two premise and unicron may wax and
wane in importance through the different
realities but they're almost always
there setting the cogs in motion for
billions of years worth of stories
in every version of the story primus in
unicron's battle comes to an end but
that end is rarely permanent primus
creates a planet cybertron by
transforming into it and spawns robotic
beings in his image to do battle against
unicron some stories refer to the 13 the
original legendary primes who set all of
transformer history in motion other
tales like idw's transformers lost light
comics speak of god-like transformers
with primus essence split between them
in the movie universe the first
transformers are called the dynasty of
primes regardless of universe though the
first transformers inevitably arise
powerful wise and ancient measuring
their lives in the billions of years
membership shifts depending on the
reality but counted among their number
have been alpha trion autobot member and
possessor of glorious robot whiskers
prima the first transformer and liege
maximo the very short-lived big bad of
the marvel generation 2 comics and of
course there's megatronus also known as
the fallen the very first decepticon
time itself is fairly irrelevant to the
origin of transformers as they live for
millions of years even the youngest of
those beings are prehistoric but few of
the transformers portrayed in the comics
and cartoons are among the firstborn on
cybertron fans of the live-action movies
might know the allspark as the source of
all transformer life a concept
introduced in the first michael bay film
the idea of the all spark grew out of
the time-bending beast wars cartoons
where the concept of a transformer's
spark was first established like a human
soul the spark is what makes each
transformer a living being when
transformers die their spark goes out
they can't just be repaired and turned
back on like machines eventually primus
and the allspark were folded into one
origin story when transformers prime
adapted the all-spark to be the vessel
through which primus created life
early cybertronian history is murky and
chaotic even in the best documented
realities warring cities battling
factions expansion into the cosmos
there's a lot of ground to cover and few
pieces of transformers media delve into
ancient events beyond passing mentions
there is one aspect of this history that
rears its ugly head time and time again
quintesons making a brief yet unsettling
debut in the 1986 animated movie our
first glimpse of the tentacled creatures
was but a taste of things to come
don't always appear at the same time in
transformer history but in every
rendition they are vicious oppressors
the five faces of darkness episodes
established that the mechanical
squid-like race had created and enslaved
the transformers before being overthrown
in newer interpretations quintessons
aren't creators but conquerors in the
2002 dreamwave comic series transformers
generation 1 the quintessons once seized
control of ancient cybertron their
eventual expulsion led to a golden age
one that lasted until megatron
discovered that the quentisson still
secretly controlled cybertron's ruling
council prompting the great war and in
netflix's war for cybertron trilogy we
learned that before megatron fought
optimus and ultra magnus the trio allied
under alpha tryon to overthrow their
quintesson masters
above any other transformer there's
always been one determined to decide his
own fate at any cost megatron you are
even lying
oh you're stupid i'm stupid i'm stupid
early megatron was fairly simple but
over the years he's transformed from a
stereotypical villain into a character
with complex motivations his story
almost always begins the same rising to
power millions of years ago in the
gladiator pits of cybertron during a
long past golden era 1986's transformers
uk annual first established this path
wherein the brutal gladiator megatron
initially aligned himself with optimus
prime in idw's megatron origin comic
book mini-series he's a pacifist who
chafes under the corrupt cybertronian
senate his descent drives him to
violence he builds a devout following
through gladiator warfare and eventually
assembles an army powerful enough to
overthrow the senate this rebellion
succeeds with help from none other than
orion pax who would go on to become
optimus prime but though megatron's rise
often begins with promise it always
results in a divided failing
cybertronian society
across transformers realities one
constant almost always remains the great
war it begins in nearly every reality
across every cybertron somewhere between
four to nine million years ago when
megatron and his decepticons declare war
on the autobots the thing is rarely
since the earliest days of the cartoon
as megatron begun the war simply out of
a desire to conquer rather the war comes
because megatron feels that only he has
the vision to lead cybertronians to
victory prosperity and eventual peace
in the aligned continuity which is
comprised of cartoons novels comics and
games starting with the war for
cybertron video game and ending with
2015's robots and disguise cartoon orion
pax and megatron both fought to
overthrow the planet's caste system but
when orion pax is chosen over megatron
to become a prime the decepticon feels
seeding jealousy and sparks the eternal
civil war in idw's the transformers
autocracy mini-series megatron joins
with orion to overthrow the tyrannical
zeta prime but once a formerly peaceful
bot gets a taste of power he is loathed
to give it up in the most recent
accounts megatron kills alpha trion
before the war for cybertron trilogy
begins because he doesn't really feel
his mentors leading the cybertronians
down the right path the active murder
splits cybertron into the autobots and
the decepticons evil is a relative term
and megatron is an especially complex
villain from his perspective the great
war nearly always begins as a rebellion
against an unfair system sadly it
usually leads him down a path where he
becomes more brutal and tyrannical than
those he once fought against
the great war rages for millions of
years devastating the transformers home
planet back in the franchise's earliest
days cybertron is so thoroughly
decimated that optimus has to lead a
contingent of autobots off world in
search of more energon the lifeblood of
the transformer race megatron pursues
the autobots and the ensuing attack
causes both factions ships to crash to
earth leading to the events of the
original cartoon in some cases there
were planet-wide tragedies that led to
prime and megatron's departure in two of
the newest renditions the war for
cybertron and cyberburst cartoons the
exodus begins when optimus ejects the
all-spark into space to keep it out of
megatron's hands with the source of all
cybertronian life missing prime only
realizes his mistake as the planet
begins to die he has no choice but to
venture to earth to recover the cube all
while the war for cybertron pushes the
planet past the point of no return
meanwhile in the world of the
transformers prime cartoon megatron's
lust for power renders cybertron
uninhabitable the decepticon leader
infects the planet with dark energon a
substance not terribly unlike our own
world's uranium after learning what
megatron had done optimus prime
determines that cybertron will take
millions of years to recover leading to
the great exodus with every autobot
fleeting to earth
while optimus and megatron lie dormant
on earth life continues on in 1996's
beast wars we turn our focus to the
maximals the future descendants of the
autobots optimus primal yes that is his
real name and no he's not related to
prime leads a small group of maximals
through warp space in pursuit of this
story's megatron this time around
megatron doesn't lead the decepticons
but their descendants the predacons
these warring factions crash land on
prehistoric earth
beast megatron has traveled back in time
after finding a message from the
original megatron with instructions to
kill the dormant optimus prime more time
travel shenanigans ensue but the
maximals ultimately fend off the
predacons and return to their own time
meanwhile in netflix's war for cybertron
kingdom the search for the allspark
lands this universe's optimus prime and
his crew in the middle of this separate
timeline's version of the beast wars
conflict after what feels like their
trillionth crash landing on earth the
autobots and decepticons meet the
maximals and predacons who have once
again traveled back in time the two
factions are born from the scant remains
of the surviving cybertronians and live
under constant threat from galvatron and
nemesis unicron's lackeys reborn from
future megatron and optimus dead bodies
it's never established exactly how far
into the future they come from the time
travel gets even more wibbly wobbly in
this universe but it firmly establishes
the prehistoric maximal and predacon
battle is an integral part to the
transformers timeline and one that's
here to stay
most transformer tales begin in the
modern era when the cybertronians bring
their war to earth inevitably entangling
humans in their alien conflict the
stories of this time are too numerous
and varied to recount but suffice it to
say you'll be hard-pressed to find a
comic cartoon or movie that doesn't drag
humans into the great war in the
original generation 1 cartoon and comics
the autobots and decepticons awaken on
earth in the 80s after lying dormant for
millions of years
some more modern tales like idw's 2005
comic series show optimists megatron and
their troops landing on earth in modern
days to begin with having never lane
dormant at all sometimes humans even
bond with transformers these human
cybertronian symbionts are one form of
what's known as a headmaster with a
human literally transforming into the
bot's head other times like in the idw
continuation transformers regeneration 1
the humans gained superpowers allowing
them to battle the giant pods whether
our planet hosts energon the all-spark
powerful artifacts or just good
old-fashioned human interference it
seems humanity's home has fated to
intersect with the transformer's endless
war
unicron was is and will be again the
massive planet-eater first threatens the
transformers in the 1986 animated film
set in the far-flung future of 2006.
unicron reformats megatron into
galvatron and creates a new more deadly
breed of decepticon stepping up to fill
the shoes of a temporarily deceased
optimus prime hot rod becomes radimus
prime and defeats the galactic devourer
once and for all sort of after unicron
was defeated in the animated film he
made a detour through the marvel comics
continuity terrorizing their universe
instead his first appearance in the
series is notable for setting up
unicron's god-like powers and his
ability to manipulate the fabric of time
pulling galvatron out of the future
since then across these timelines and
multiverses unicron's return has become
all but inevitable in 2018 after over a
decade of avoiding the ultimate evil idw
comics finally brought unicronk back
with a vengeance the massive battle
unified the transformers and brought 13
years of comic book battle to an end
unicron also appears in the live-action
movies where transformers the last night
reveals that unicron is the earth itself
so it seems that we've not seen the last
of the planet eater after all
nearly every transformer story brings
the robots to earth as they flee
cybertron but there is one notable
exception 2001's transformers robots and
disguise cartoon is a bit of a wild card
robots in disguise does take place on
earth but instead of an ancient war
spilling over onto our planet this
particular show sees optimus prime
leading his autobots to prevent megatron
and his predacons from locating an
ancient cybertronian secret the
immensely powerful fortress maximus the
show never gets into these transformers
history much but there are some
interesting quirks to unpack this
version of ultra magnus for instance is
optimus prime's brother rather than an
old friend and on the topic of quirks
who could forget megatron's six-changer
form in this reality the predacon can
transform into among other things a
giant floating hand a bat and a
two-headed dragon as for the decepticons
the only ones in the entire universe are
created when megatron gets his hands on
a small handful of autobot protoforms
essentially blank slates and brainwashes
them into sinister new creations robots
in disguise was the first time a
japanese-produced transformer series was
adapted for western audiences born from
the car robots anime this adaptation was
also the first taste of what would
become countless official transformers
reboots before this point each new comic
or cartoon would simply tweak generation
1's continuity to fit its plot but
robots in disguise cut the timeline
loose and gave creators free reign as a
result transformers lore has since run
wildly in every imaginable direction
[Laughter]
i found my very own minicon and megatron
will love me for this launched in 2004
transformers armada was the second full
reboot to the transformers timeline in
the world of armada there aren't just
autobots and decepticons there's also a
third faction called minicons in this
timeline unicron disguises himself as a
cybertronian moon and creates some mini
cons to kick the autobot and decepticon
war into high gear the tiny bots have
the ability to boost the power of their
larger brethren naturally leading to the
autobots and decepticons struggling for
control over this new breed of
transformers eventually both factions
realize the mini cons are too dangerous
and cast them off into the far reaches
of space predictably the minicons end up
on earth where they are rediscovered
millions of years later by the
cybertronians this brings the
transformers into the modern era and as
is tradition drags humans into their
fight unicron is defeated by the end of
armada but his story continues in two
more series transformers enter jon jumps
into the then near future of 2010 and
chronicles yet another resurrection of
the planet eater transformers cybertron
sees the transformers fleeing to earth
after the black hole left by unicron's
destruction threatens their home planet
though it's one of the pillars of the
transformers multiverse this alternate
timeline had quite a few detractors and
the repeated focus on unicron left
audiences more than a little burnt out
though 2007's live action transformers
initially seemed to be a faithful homage
to generation 1 it would quickly grow
into an entirely new beast the
transformers in michael bay's films are
not creations of primus but of a
mysterious alien race not so cleverly
dubbed the creators the later films
retconned a lot about the earlier ones
but the important parts is that the
transformers come to earth about 19 000
years before modern times at this point
the cybertronians plan to harvest our
sun for energon until they discover
humans and mostly agree not to wipe us
out but the fallen one of the original
transformers from the dynasty of primes
wants to take the sun anyways this
sparks the division of the transformers
and the formation of the decepticons in
other words this is a rare timeline
where the great war isn't sparked by
megatron but his master the fallen is
eventually defeated but the war rages on
a recurring habit to the bay films is to
interweave cybertronian history into our
own in the 2007 film they're revealed to
have been responsible for humanity's
technological advancement in dark of the
moon they're the reason for the space
race in age of extinction the creators
were responsible for eradicating the
dinosaurs and according to the last
knight they aided king arthur and fought
alongside the allied forces in both
world wars the transformers had been on
earth for centuries by the events of the
first film but the autobot decepticon
war flares up once again when the
all-spark was rediscovered kicking off
the entire live-action series
it's you and me megatron no it's just me
prime
then 2018's bumblebee once again changed
the live-action universe and rebooted
the entire story instead of transformers
landing on earth millions of years ago
bumblebee becomes the first autobot to
land on earth in 1987. he encounters a
couple of decepticons who also landed on
earth as he awaits the arrival of
optimus prime and other autobots as they
flee the war happening on cybertron
while much of transformers passed is
relegated to hazy constantly changing
myths the future remains a diverging
branch of possibilities in 2008's
transformers animated the autobots win
the great war by shooting the all-spark
into space and keeping its power out of
megatron's hands ultra magnus then leads
the autobots to victory after which
cybertron thrives while megatron and the
decepticons flee to the fringes as
renegades this iteration of optimus
prime is just a young asteroid miner who
stumbles upon the allspark years later
in modern times the inevitable clash
between his crew and megatron sends them
crashing to earth where they lie dormant
for just 50 years when they awaken a
22nd century earth they find the planet
awash in robots thanks to a human
scientist who reverse engineered
megatron's body and created his own
mechanical life animated is one of the
more unique takes on transformers
history two beast wars characters even
make an appearance black arachnia and
waspinator if it weren't so wildly
detached from established series lore
this next generation continuity could
have been an interesting bridge between
the robotic transformers of past and
present in the tech organic bots of the
future
in a franchise as diverging and messy as
transformers it's hard to say which
ending is the definitive finale but one
particular series provides a better
candidate than others the beast wars
sequel series beast machines
the predacon leader enslaves all of
cybertron reformatting maximals and
predacons alike into mindless drone
servants the beast machines cartoon is a
dark dystopian tale where a handful of
maximals led by optimus primal fight a
guerrilla battle in a war that was over
before it started the story introduces a
number of fascinating concepts
transformers are more like cyborgs and
beast machines as they embrace their
organic sides and become techno-organic
creatures ones that don't so much
transform rather morphing between their
alternate forms what are we robots or
animals
both
and neither well that sure clears it up
this future even has botanica what is
believed to be the only plant-based
transformer in all the multiversal
timeline the series ends with maximals
freeing cybertron for megatron's control
thereby saving the planet the entire
transformer race is reborn into foley
tech organic beans ushering in a new
golden age of cybertron outside of the
beast machines cartoon this future was
only ever briefly explored in a couple
of short-lived comic books so while this
techno-organic cybertronian destiny
isn't quite a universal ending it
provides the closest thing to a final
happy ending the transformers franchise
has ever received
[Music]